it's finally happening hbo max is going
to release the snyder cut
the four-hour long zak snyder's justice
league is a legend born of tragedy
in the midst of working on justice
league snyder suffered a family loss
and stepped away as production was
nearing its end warner brothers then
brought joss whedon across comic book
lines to finish the film
since he'd already proven his superhero
team-up chops with the marvel cinematic
universes
marvelously successful the avengers
however whedon didn't simply finish what
snyder had started he rewrote and
re-shot the vast majority of the movie
and to quote the boys warner brothers
decided that the new jazz rewrite really
sings
well fans didn't feel the same justice
league was released in november 2017
and was promptly declared a huge
disappointment it awkwardly mixed
weeden's patented snappy dialogue
with snyder's austere vibe while also
struggling to introduce the newest team
members
so it wasn't long until fans and stars
like gal gadot and ben affleck
took to twitter demanding that warner
hashtag released the snyder cut
now it's finally time zack snyder's
justice league arrives march 18th on hbo
max
here's everything you need to know at
first the so-called slider cut existed
simply as unfinished footage with no
special effects
but that didn't stop fans from flying a
plane over 2019's san diego comic-con
with the message warner brothers hashtag
released the snyder curt of justice
league
or collecting over 100 000 signatures on
a change.org petition
snyder joined in continuously teasing
his version of the film and social media
two years after justice league premiered
warner brothers decided to take a chance
on it and that snyder and his wife
deborah
who's worked as a producer on nearly
every dc eu movie
if they would come back to the project
with a reported 70 million dollar budget
the snyder's set to work to turn would
have been abandoned three years
previously
into a polished movie the four-hour long
preliminary curt already existed in
january of 2017
but much of the original footage never
made it into the theatrical cut
snyder who's never seen the theatrical
release said to the hollywood reporter
it will be an entirely new thing and
especially talking to those who have
seen the release movie
a new experience apart from that movie
you probably saw one fourth of what i
did
in fact snyder's intended justice league
story was supposed to be told across
three movies
but considering the theatrical cuts box
office failure and a packed slate of dc
projects on the horizon
it seems unlikely that warner brothers
will move forward with the sequels
regardless of the new version streaming
success
still its existence represents a huge
triumph for fans of snyder's vision
while the theatrical curt of justice
league saw the introduction of victor
stone aka cyborg
into the dc eu much of his story was
actually cut out of the film
according to ray fisher who said that
whedon's justice league set was an
abusive work environment
nearly every cyborg seen in justice
league was a reshoot
and the snyder cut will feature large
amounts of previously
unseen footage of him it's expected to
include his origin story
complete with scenes of cyborg learning
to use his new abilities
snyder said at dc's virtual fandom event
in 2020
cyborg is the heart of the movie cyborg
is the thing in the end that holds the
team together in a lot of ways
aside from cyborg the flash and aquaman
will get more fleshed out stories as
well the snyders told thr
what's so lovely about this is that we
get to explore these characters in ways
that you're not able to in a shorter
theatrical version
even the leading trio of batman superman
and wonder woman will see some changes
snyder has teased that superman will be
wearing a black suit in contrast to his
usual red and blue
while character inconsistencies with
previous films like the murderous wonder
woman
will be fixed plus several of the actors
recorded extra dialogue
and even shot new scenes for the
director's cut so it's sure to have a
lot of material that fans have never
seen before
by this point a few trailers for zack
snyder's justice league has already set
fans of burst with the excitement that
the famed dc villain darkseid
will finally make his appearance played
by ray porter he's the supreme leader of
the planet apocalypse
and the true big bad behind justice
league's villain steppenwolf
he never appeared in whedon's version of
the film though and still has an
uncertain role in the snyder cut
at ign fan fest snyder said he's quote
the sequel bad guy but assured fans that
he's definitely in it
it's unclear just what steppenwolf and
darkseid's plot will be in the
director's cut
but snyder teased that their very
complicated relationship
will be a part of it he said i'm not
going to give it away but the dynamic
between the two of them
some things happened in the past there's
a bunch of issues between them and so
yeah i think that all plays out yes the
answer is there's quite a complex
relationship there
several other characters including the
flash's love interest iris west
martian manhunter and the atom will all
make appearances
on top of that joe manganiello's
deathstroke will play a bigger role
even teaming up with batman previously
he was only seen in the post-credits
scene
being recruited to the legion of doom by
lex luthor
but manganello has reportedly shot new
footage for the snyder cut
while zack snyder's justice league began
as a realization of snyder's original
vision for the film
at least one element will be completely
new jared leto's joker
first introduced in suicide squad with
the word damaged prettily scrawled
across his forehead
the joker was never in the original plan
for justice league
which at the very least saved the cast
from letos reported in character gifts
but snyder had long wanted to explore
joker and batman's fraught relationship
in the dc eu
he told vanity fair so he decided to
bring him into the fold for the
director's cut
this isn't the dark knight though so the
joker isn't going to be the main event
in fact snyder has already revealed what
the joke is doing in justice league
spoiler alert he appears as a harbinger
of chaos in bruce wayne's nightmare
vision
of a world where darkseid successfully
invades earth
it's a warning for bruce about the
pressing threat but it's also an
opportunity to dive into their history
snyder said the cool thing about the
scene is that it's joker talking
directly to batman about batman
it's joker analyzing batman about who he
is and what he is
that's the thing i also felt like fans
deserved from the dc universe that is to
say the jared leto joker and the ben
affleck batman they never really got
together it seemed uncool to me that we
would make it all the way through this
incarnation of batman and joker
without seeing them come together
despite all the buzz over zack snyder's
justice league it ultimately will not be
part of the dceu's canon going forward
think of it like a different timeline of
events snyder said at ign fan fest
i think you can view my snyder verse
version of the dc superhero
canon as its own thing i love patty
jenkins and james 1 and what they've
done with their movies and are amazing
but at this point i was just like this
is its own thing
and it doesn't really owe anything to
anything so i'm just going to do it
exactly as i had always intended
he also offered advanced warning that
the film ends on a cliffhanger because
of his original three movie plan
unfortunately fans may never see whether
the heroes fall off that proverbial
cliff
or pull themselves back up but even if
there are no further sequels
fans can at least take solace in the
news that there will be two different
versions
of the snyder cut the standard one
hitting hbo max on march 18th
and the black and white version
nicknamed justice is grey
that will arrive on the streaming
platform at a later date overall the
film will have many visual differences
from the theatrical release
from steppenwolf's new design to the
aspect ratio to the color of the sky
on top of that the music will be
different until the new version debuts
it's hard to say just how much more fans
will appreciate zack snyder's justice
league
than they did joss whedon's 2017 cut but
we can certainly expect it to be
different
for an extra special viewing experience
you can even watch it with zak snyder
himself in a virtual screening
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superhero movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you